coup de projecteur à présent sur une
initiative solidaire toute cette semaine
le centre de loisirs de la chartre est à
chambray les tours accueille des enfants
en situation de handicap un nouveau
public pour ce domaine de 30 hectares
qui appartient à la ville de tours de 3
à 5 enfants sont pris en charge chaque
jour car ils ne peuvent plus se rendre
dans leurs structures habituelles une
solution de garde pour permettre
également à leurs parents de souffler un
peu paul boyer
ce sont plusieurs dizaines d'enfants qui
profitent du centre de loisirs de la
charte près depuis lundi tous souffrent
d'un handicap mental plus ou moins
sévères le temps d'une journée ils
profitent de ce cadre idyllique pour
jouer se divertir encadrés par des
professionnels de santé
ils sont en train de faire du
transvasement avec de la semoule
d'autres jouent au ballon ja on a fait
de la peinture on va faire des balades
ils sont allés il ya des petites
structures de jeu on a écouté de la
musique on a lu des histoires
voilà comme un centre de loisirs j'ai
envie de dire mais avec des boeufs des
enfants qu'on peut t'on des besoins plus
spécifiques donc on adapte aussi les
choses avec avec la particularité des
enfants pour peggy maman de sony état
aux deux enfants de 5 et 7 ans on est
avec des troubles autistiques
cette journée de repos était inespéré on
a pas du tout de répit nous à la maison
c'est faux c'est une attention tout le
temps ce qui est sont pas du tout
conscient du danger ils sont voilà c'est
des frères qui se met un peu dessus
aussi puis ils sont très brutaux donc
ouais non nous c'est vraiment de pouvoir
souffler avec le confinement la plupart
des centres médico sociaux ont fermé le
but de cette initiative est de laisser
un peu de répit aux parents qui ne
peuvent ni faire garder leurs enfants ni
les emmener au travail est compliqué
pour les parents donc c'est vrai que le
soir on voit que les parents sont
contentes d'avoir pu passer une journée
un peu off pour leur permettre de
souffler et de récupérer l'enfant le
soir elle en vain la preuve que ça les
fatigue pas mal le centre de loisirs de
la charte près accueillerait des enfants
handicapés jusqu'à vendredi
des week-ends seront bientôt organisées
afin de continuer d'aider certains
parents